which Pokemon would you go for a drink
with down the pub well I'm a chump cause
he can old for point he just bruised
through the bar with me with four points
yeah Matt ampitheatre one this is versus
the games might show that pits your
favorite games consoles franchises and
hot-button issues against each other
this week Pokemon was it better back in
the day or are we all blinded by a
nostalgia arguing the case for Pokemon
generations one two three aka the ones
that make you all nostalgic is Oscar
Deus who was only a year old when the
first game came out yeah let that sink
in and fighting for pokémon generations
four to seven is will Potter who 100%
identifies as a slowpoke no heed you're
going to argue the corner for their game
over the course of three randomly picked
topics with the overall winner being
decided by you the wonderful viewers
last week's fight between Call of Duty
and Battlefield saw me destroy will with
an absolutely savage 81 percent of the
vote for my battlefield argument anyway
to vote for who you think argue their
case better on this episode we're going
to be throwing up a clickable polls
right here on YouTube right let's get
into the debate
[Music]
a wild Oscar appears yeah a wild Oscar
please prick bill I've got one objective
and one objective only in this video
what's that mate I wanna be the very
best like no one ever was pound pound
pound catch them is my real test to
train them is my cause Pokemon guys too
early in it yeah they all first topic
creature design no I think no I think
Jen's one swim free of this pretty much
nailed nailed because clearly they're so
iconic right the the original three
games particularly the original 151 are
so iconic yeah and that's why that if
you look at how popular Pokemon go was
for example that was because originally
it was just the original 151 I don't
think that game would have been anywhere
near as popular if it was just gen 7 put
come on for example a lot of the
original one that you want on
particularly imaginative in terms of
their designs but their simplicity is
what makes them easier to sort of
understand and even if you look at the
the legendaries as well can remember how
amazing it was to capture Zapdos or molt
res or mu or Mewtwo or any of the
legendaries from the first three
generations it felt amazing it felt so
special words and the later gens there's
about a million legendaries and it's
like I don't get excited about catching
Heatran you know I mean or I think what
Akram I think the problem though is that
you are this is very much fueled by your
nostalgia but don't let that get in the
way of like good design I think some of
the recent Pokemon are great because
they have to think more now they're like
we've already done like hundreds of
Pokemon we need to think and and come up
with new creatures that haven't been
done before and that's why you get
pokémon like mimic you which has got
this kind of tragic backstory which is
like it's this unpopular ghost Pokemon
who wants to be just like Pikachu who
everyone loves so it makes it a zone
like Pikachu disguise and pretends to be
this popular cute pokémon
do not think that is sort of a weird
metaphor for the Pokemon series in
itself and that it's trying to dress
itself as something which is used to be
more popular than it is now it was at
its peak in sort of mid to late 90s and
probably again a year or two ago with
with Pokemon go and the reason that I
would say those are its two peaks of
popularity is that those two times both
included just Gen one and then
everything in between and everything
sort of latter-day Gen 4 5 6 7
I don't think Pokemon has really hit the
same heights and I think that's because
primarily because the designs just
aren't as fun as what they were yeah but
I think there are so some really cool
Pokemon like even though even right
Litton is a cute Pokemon it like it's
not a bad design like it's still a great
Pokemon and in sinner or is badass and
is as cool I think as Torre's are not
only do you have that but they take the
original Pokemon and make them better
with mega evolutions yeah again you're
with the mega evolutions and mimic you
just still leaning on the original 151
and the other thing as well about the
creatures is that I have really disliked
the introduction of fairy type fairy
types were brought in because dragon
types were overpowered so they brought
in the fairies the counter dragons and I
think some of the fairy-type pokémon
which are being retro actively applied
to the older Pokemon makes sense like it
makes more sense to have a broader range
and it makes the game more interesting
it's not just rock-paper-scissors you're
now getting staplers and pencils and
everything every kind of stationary
matter I don't know where I'm going it's
an analogy for Pokemon sorry okay story
characters I think from like black and
white on had better more interesting
stories black and white you had team
plasma and n who basically trying to
free Pokemon it was quite interesting it
was like should people be able to own
Pokemon and you know use them as tools
and then in Sun and Moon like recently
it got quite dark like you had team
skull
Tim who are the coolest villains by the
way team skull team up with the ether
foundation to open up wormholes to ultra
space allowing ultra beasts which is
crazy weird monsters and lucemon a is
your makes mum and turns out she's crazy
and obsessed with using these Pokemon
it's it's good that Pokemon has a bit
more of a story and actually the the
later games feel more anime because they
feel more like an actual story it's way
more interesting whereas the original
games you want to be the best water
catch them all but felt like that was
the was to it yeah I think I think
you're right in that the stories have
definitely got a lot more complex and a
lot more thoughtful probably as the
years have gone on and actually black
and white story in particular I thought
was really really cool unfortunately I
think the characters within those
stories are really really dull I think a
prime example is the how rivals have
evolved from like silver for example
like they they were so interesting
because they were horrible right they
were actual rivals they kicked you and
they stole things and you felt like you
actually wanted to beat them right that
was where for me I didn't need a grand
plot about saving humanity or anything
like that I just wanted interesting
characters to pull me through that story
whatever that story was and they were
far more interesting than how who is a
guy who is nice and likes food that's
not a character you know and the same
with a lot of the characters in the late
game particularly the rivals I think the
rivals have really gone to pop but what
about the Ezell em had green hair and he
was this conflicted like emo kid who
started off like really righteous but
then in the end like he realized his
mistakes that to me is more interesting
than the very two-dimensional and he has
the games were just like well he's nasty
so we're gonna fight all the time but no
but that's what I think if you look at
different aspects of the games in the
the evil teams that you face-off I think
they fall foul of that exact thing that
you just said because like team skull
what a team's goal stand for being bad
because it's the dress senses they
looked cool doing it I mean they looked
cool doing it
but they were ridiculous and they fell
over and they were useless and they were
a terrible evil team whereas someone
like Team Magma
or Team Aqua I think had a genuine
motivation like you can see what they
wanted to achieve and those two teams
coming together caused a genuine clash
and an interesting conflict right
whereas team skull is like you're evil I
guess
and it's like great yeah you look cool
but like what are you doing what are you
doing in this world why do I care about
you I don't I don't care about team
Scholl I don't care about team flare I
don't care about you bill I don't want
to go home well I think you're wrong
next topic is worlds all interesting
it's pretty clear to me that Kanto Johto
and Hoenn are far superior that to
anything that's seen in the late ones
but other than that I think those those
original three are by far the best
because I think what they do amazingly
well is they illustrate the scale of
your journey so well and that when you
first start off in all three you're in a
really tiny little town with little
almost shacks four houses it feels very
much like small beginnings and then a
huge finish what I really dislike about
the later ones is that you sort of come
to the really big cities like far too
soon and then it's like wow look at this
amazing place and then it's sort of a
bit of an anti-climax after that if you
see what I mean whereas like I say in
the early ones you build up to those
amazing points when I think of Kalos for
example I can remember lumiose and
outside of lumiose I can't remember a
single town in that game I just find
them sort of blending into one whereas
whole and each town is so different from
the last and so I think there's they
keep you interesting for so much longer
my favorite thing though about the later
games was that they started to look
outside for influence in black and white
you hadn't / which was based on New York
City in X&Y you had caliphs which was
based on France and then sort of moon a
Lolo is based on Hawaii so I think
you've got three very very different
games and that affected the aesthetic of
the whole game so for me that's way more
interesting and that plays into every
element of the game like an Sun and Moon
it plays into like
No you've got islands and you've got
trials and it feels much more like yes
this is a believable setting the
original games were apparently based on
Japan but to me that I wouldn't have
known that unless I was told it didn't
look like anywhere in particular my X&Y
based on France yes it does that very
French and it feels like I'm in another
country it felt exciting to go somewhere
new there's nice to see Game Freak
finally bring in sort of outside
influences into their games that's cool
but within each of those regions
it wasn't visually distinct enough for
me at least because like you say they're
all distinct from one another in terms
of you know is different to Sinnoh is
different et cetera whereas in the
original three in Kanto Johto and ho and
you have that variety within each game
do you have metropolis and then you have
small town and then you have desert and
then you have see and then you have a
gym I mean and I don't like the fact
that gyms were completely lost in a lola
that was like the worst bit about a lola
for me like i really missed the gyms and
the structure that they bring the trials
were cool but they should have been a
side thing for me rather than replacing
gyms i think they have just as much
diversity as the other games I think
they're just forgetting like they have
deserts jungles mountains incredible
cities like the best cities and cities
are my favorite parts of any Pokemon
game yeah that's what everything happens
like I guess we can talk about this as
well like ride Pokemon like instead of
having to learn moves like hit machines
to make your way through the world
instead you just ring up pour offs and
buy for it make can we just go through
here please yeah no problem
or Machamp will pick you up and walk
cool I would love to be picked up by my
champion woods I reckon he's like what
rough skills lessons taught directly I
reckon he moisturizes yeah but I mean if
he doesn't happily do it for him yeah
bet you would
[Laughter]
we'll wrap things up with that
disturbing statement but who do you
think won the debate let us know by
voting in our pot in the top right
corner of the video or if you're over on
GameSpot calm by putting your thoughts
in the comment section below
it'll be your votes who decide who wins
so make yourselves heard right time for
this week's quickfire round a series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the UK team let's see how well an
Oscar get on
do an impression of your favorite
Pokemon I'll just slowpoke slow baking
my favorite yeah slow I have to work
with this man
how many Pokemon can you name in 10
seconds all right you go first
Bulbasaur ever saw that Venus or
Charmander Charmeleon Charizard squirt a
water
Blastoise Pikachu PG right Shu cyndaquil
I forgot to time here ah which Pokemon
would you go for a drink with down the
pub Pikachu's probably a good lad I
reckon he gets wasted after about half a
point though yeah he's ponies leave but
what about Machamp because you can old
for point he just bruised through the
bar with me with 4 points yeah my
champion Peter 1 yeah what is
categorically in your unbiased opinion
the worst Pokemon
I mean it's trubbish isn't it no no
troubles into garbodor which is amazing
it's the second one us Pokemon know
that's an amazing Pokemon Dunsparce yeah
Dunsparce is terrible you're right you
if you were a Pokemon you'd be done spot
unclearly a slowpoke away you're a
[ __ ] idiot that's what we say in
which of these is not a Pokemon spotlit
mega prick oh wow kids TV show
it does actually spotlit I'm going
spotlit it's the real one they're all
not real nothing is a real spotlit isn't
a Pokemon getting so mister mine mr. Mun
[Laughter]
rice
remember to get your voice heard now
Paul or in the comment section below and
tell us who you think argued their case
better and if you enjoyed this episode
of vs. make sure to hit that subscribe
button as we'll have new episodes of
this show every Wednesday
thanks for watching see ya
[Music]
you